welcome to cbs this morning election day
can you believe this is 15 days away and
counting the presidential campaigns
are now making their closing arguments
to the voters and you probably notice
somebody's missing at the table but
happy to tell you not from the show
this week tony decouple he's on the road
for a series of reports we're calling
at america's crossroads right now he's
visiting three
key battleground states starting in
michigan this morning he's in suburban
detroit in one of the counties
that president trump flipped from blue
to red back in 2016.
it's being hotly contested again tony
good morning to you
hey good morning guys and welcome to
michigan we're being well taken care of
here maze diner has opened up early
we are well fueled but we got a lot of
news to get to so i'm going to jump into
it we're in mount clemons that's in
macomb county michigan
and that is a crucial battleground in
the 2020 election it is a swing county
in what is a swing state which is why
our road trip and the road to the white
house
run straight through here i want to give
you some of the big pictures so you can
understand it all there are more than
688
000 registered voters in this blue
collar county
two times they voted for former
president obama before flipping
and going for president trump in 2016 by
a big margin in fact
but the president won the state only
barely he got those 16 electoral votes
by a razor thin
margin he beat hillary clinton here by
fewer than 11
000 votes that is less than one percent
what's the race doing right now well in
the latest cbs news battleground
tracker poll we've got joe biden leading
president trump in michigan
52 to 46 percent but it is still
very close and you can tell because both
candidates have visited this state
three times just since their nominations
were set
in august coming up in the broadcast
you're going to hear from democratic
governor
and joe biden's campaign co-chair about
the alleged plot to kidnap her plus what
she thinks
of the president who joined a chant over
the weekend of lock her up
saying lock them all up we're also
talking to voters here about the issues
that matter most to them
and this is important here because
negativity can really drive voting we
talk to voters about the issues
that are getting their blood boiling in
2020.
there's a long list of them meanwhile
president trump is focused on some other
critical states out in the west he's
holding rallies in arizona later today
that is the state he won last time but
the latest cbs news battleground tracker
poll
suggests that joe biden as of this
moment has an edge he's up by about
three points